bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct notre grand témoin ce soir et
l'auteur de la première histoire
européenne du djihadisme bonsoir Hugo
Miss France et merci d'être là la colère
et l'oubli chez Gallimard les
démocraties face au djihadisme européen
c'est un livre extrêmement fouillé à
l'armant aussi que vous venez de publier
Allemagne Danemark France - Belgique
Royaume-Uni c'est autant une histoire
que une géographie on y reviendra sur le
djihadisme qui ne se réduit pas aux
attentats vous nous direz pourquoi
malgré les flux et les reflux et bien ce
djihadisme est toujours là tapis dans
l'ombre on y revient longuement dans la
deuxième partie mais on commence ce soir
par cette question jusqu'où ira la
violence en politique le maire de
Saint-Brévin poussé à la démission et
sortie du silence aujourd'hui il dénonce
je cite un attentat contre lui et met en
cause l'État qui ne l'a pas protégé des
violences qui s'ajoutent à l'agression
du petit neveu de Brigitte Macron
c'était lundi soir à Amiens violence
inacceptable auquel on s'habitue c'est
sans doute une partie du problème alors
quelle sursaut possibilité qui sont les
responsables grands débats dans un
instant avec mes invités sur ce plateau
avant de retrouver à 20h15 nos
affranchis pour leur parti pris et puis
Bourbon Express l'histoire du jour bien
sûr à l'Assemblée nationale voilà pour
le menu vous me suivez Hugo Miss rond ça
vous regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
il est devenu le visage de la violence
faite aux élus Yannick Moret le maire de
Saint-Brévin poussé à la démission après
l'incendie d'une partie de sa maison
menacée intimidée par l'extrême droite
il dénonce un manque de soutien de
l'État devant les sénateurs aujourd'hui
et il est ce soir reçu par Elisabeth
borne à Matignon on va donc revenir sur
cette violence contre les politiques
après le tabassage aussi du petit neveu
de Brigitte Macron lundi soir 2265
agressions et menaces contre les élus
recensés par le ministère de l'Intérieur
en 2022 bonsoir Sabrina agressé roubach
ce soir ravi de vous accueillir sur ce
plateau vous êtes député renaissance des
Bouches-du-Rhône vous débattez ce soir
avec deux de vos collègues Paul Vanier
bonsoir merci d'être là député la France
insoumise du Val-d'Oise et membre de la
nupes bonsoir Julien Odoul bonsoir
bienvenue député rassemblement national
de l'Yonne enfin bonsoir et bienvenue
Antoine oberdore merci d'être là vous
êtes journaliste à La Croix et vous avez
enquêté à Saint-Brevin vous avez
rencontré tous les acteurs le maire mais
pas seulement on va y revenir dans le
détail vous signez un grand papier
aujourd'hui sur les mères menacées
agressées mais qui tiennent bon malgré
tout ce qu'ils vivent gomicheron en tant
que citoyen évidemment cette violence
nous interpelle alors n'hésitez pas à
intervenir ou même à questionner nos
invités on va commencer par revenir sur
les faits de Amiens à Saint-Brévin il a
200 secondes c'est un défi le chrono de
Blacko c'est parti
bonsoir Stéphane datowski bonsoir Myriam
bonsoir à toutes et tous alors c'est
violent alors si on peut commencer par
une chanson je vais peut-être citer deux
verres de Brassens qui dit le pluriel ne
vaut rien à l'homme et sitôt qu'on n'est
plus de 4 on est une bande de cons donc
hier soir ils étaient carrément 10 à
frapper Jean-Baptiste trogneux au sol
donc vous imaginez un peu le niveau de
conneries qui régnait dans cette petite
bande d'ailleurs trois d'entre eux vont
dormir en prison ce soir alors dans la
classe politique évidemment personne n'a
pris la défense des agresseurs mais j'ai
trouvé que le tweet de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon était assez révélateur au-delà
du temps un peu méprisant pour le
chocolatier trogneux ce qui est
franchement c'est que ce qui lui tient à
cœur dans son Z8 c'est surtout de
revendiquer pour lui aussi le rôle de
victime de violence simplement il dit
que lorsqu'on agresse les insoumis et
ben on en parle jamais donc c'est un peu
de la rhétorique de cours de récré c'est
pas moi c'est lui donc la gauche dit que
la violence vient de l'extrême droite et
la gauche dit bah non pas du tout ça
vient de l'ultra gauche alors de ce
point de vue le témoignage du maire de
Saint-Brévin était intéressant ce matin
de devant le Sénat parce que lui il
clairement été victime d'une attaque de
harcèlement venu de l'extrême droite et
pourtant il met l'extrême droite et
l'ultra gauche dans le même sac parce
que selon son expérience quand les
fachos mobilisent elle m'a l'ultra
gauche n'est jamais très loin on
l'écoute
250 personnes sont venus
ont bloqué la ville les commerces ont
créé également des
des dégâts puisque bien entendu qui dit
manifestations d'extrême droite vous
avez en face l'ultra gauche également
qui appelle à venir tout simplement pour
se taper dessus
vous voyez que dans son cas il n'est pas
le tort uniquement d'un côté pourtant à
Saint-Brévin c'est clairement l'extrême
droite qui a mené une action contre le
cadastre c'est-à-dire le centre
d'accueil des demandeurs d'asile après
tout pourquoi pas parce que c'est assez
efficace ce type de mobilisation je vais
vous citer un cas qui est arrivé dans
les Côtes-d'Armor de une commune qui
s'appelle Kalak ou le maire a renoncé un
projet donc de centre d'accueil sous la
pression du harcèlement parce que il y
avait des menaces de morts des menaces
de viol contre son conseil municipal et
curieusement
Eric Zemmour était très satisfait il a
même félicité les militants qui avaient
mené
cette bataille donc de ce point de vue
là sachant que l'extrême droite est
arrivé assez fin à Callac on aura pu se
penser que l'État aurait pris ses
précautions pour ça n'arrive pas à
nouveau à sa Brévin ça paraît assez
logique d'autant que c'est l'État qui a
imposé qui a décidé d'installer ce
centre d'accueil dans la commune et pas
le maire unique Moret et ben pas du tout
parce que quand Yannick Moret avant que
sa maison prend incendie finit par
obtenir un rendez-vous avec le
sous-préfet et un responsable de l'enjeu
d'armurerie et qu'il a fait preuve de
ses parts de ses craintes voilà ce qu'on
lui a répondu
le sous-préfet nous a tout simplement
dit mais les menaces mais vous savez moi
j'en ai tous les jours des menaces
le commandant de gendarmerie vous savez
c'est pas grand chose ce sont simplement
des des menaces voilà c'est de
l'intimidation
ça ne sert à rien de déposer plein de
toute façon on ne fera rien c'est la
liberté d'expression
alors en ce moment vous savez bien que
des gens qui s'inquiètent pour l'avenir
et de la démocratie c'est vraiment parce
qu'il manque et les tribunes plein la 13
des grands discours en veux-tu donc
voilà donc le maire de Saint-Brévin n'a
peut-être pas l'éloquence de toutes ces
grands penseurs mais simplement il a
pour lui la sincérité et lui quand il
s'inquiète pour l'avenir de la
démocratie c'est vraiment quelque chose
de très concret il va pas chercher très
loin il se dit mais si on arrête pas la
violence très rapidement politique mais
comment on va faire pour avoir des
candidats ou municipales en 2026 on
écoute et on s'aperçoit également dans
plein de petites communes et je vois mon
niveau de mon interco beaucoup de
petites communes n'avaient qu'une liste
il y a même une commune de CorSec et
juste à côté de Saint-Brévin ou la liste
elle s'est vraiment faite trois jours
trois jours avant le dépôt c'était
vraiment donc en 2026 qu'est-ce qui va
se passer donc c'était touchant
intéressant d'entendre Yannick Moret ce
matin mais je rappelle que c'est juste
un cas que le nombre de violences contre
les élus augmentaient 32% en 2022 donc
il y a vraiment un débat et surtout des
solutions à trouver on va essayer
peut-être à notre humble au niveau merci
beaucoup Stéphane on va commencer par ce
qui s'est passé à Saint-Brévin Sabrina
bon c'est une affaire gravissime
qu'est-ce qui est le plus grave dans
cette affaire selon où est-ce que c'est
que l'extrême droite d'une certaine
façon soit parvenue à ses fins avec
cette démission du maire ou est-ce que
l'État cette faillite de l'État n'est
pas à mettre en couple de clairement
clairement puisque moi ce qui me
connaissent un petit peu je suis pas du
genre
au débit non c'est pas que je domine
j'ai un moment donné quand vous avez un
sous-préfet qui vous répond vous savez
moi aussi aura des menaces c'est rien
non c'est pas rien parce que les mots se
transforment en acte la réalité c'est
que ce qui s'est passé c'est un brevet
c'est que on a un maire menacé on le
savait puisqu'il l'a expliqué moi je
l'ai suivi on ne voulait pas de ce cada
donc de ce centre d'accueil chez lui on
le lui a fait savoir
il a été menacé les gens ont été
intimidés et qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
comme la maintenant le le mode de
fonctionnement en fait en gros être
violence balader allez dire Macron va
décapiter oui non mais non mais c'est
pas ça c'est que pour des gens
structurés ça reste des mots pour des
gens un peu moins structurés ça devient
des actes mais quand vous dites le
sous-préfet n'était pas à la hauteur la
leçon préférée c'est l'état c'est l'état
non mais moi j'ai pas de mal parce que
c'est lui qui le procure de la
République qui répond pas ou à la
dernière minute quand c'est trop tard
moi il faut rappeler que l'indemnité sur
pour les petits mères dans les petites
communes sont très très faibles donc et
je l'ai toujours dit vous voulez faire
de l'argent vous faites toute politique
faites pas de politique surtout pas vous
fuyez la chose c'est que c'est un vrai
engagé moi j'ai répondu je vous dis j'ai
fait il faudra tirer le son y compris
une interview la semaine dernière où je
disais moi je me suis posé la question
qu'est-ce que moi j'aurais fait si on
s'en était pris à ma famille et ben
j'aurais fait exactement comme lui
exactement comme lui j'aurais pris mes
affaires j'aurais pris ma famille je me
serais barré c'est ça que j'aurais fait
et la réalité c'est que quand il parle
écoutez ce qu'il dit extreme droite
l'extrême gauche vient mais pas pour
dire on veut le CADA où on veut pas le
CADA c'est pour un d'écoute pour faire
la même c'est-à-dire pour répondre à la
violence par la violence moi qui suis
née dans un milieu violent je suis né
dans des quartiers les plus pauvres je
sais ce que c'est d'avoir un corps avec
des balles de kalachnikov ça je sais et
quand je vois qu'il y a des élus qui
trouve ça super drôle ça c'est
guignolesque c'est marrant non c'est pas
marrant parce que certains ont la
structure intellectuelle encore une fois
pour dire c'est drôle on fait du guignol
on fait pas du guignol on vous le
déséphigie mais pour des gens moins
structurés il se passe ça c'est ça qui
se passe et un jour et je l'ai dit je
l'ai écrit il y a deux ans dans mon
livre je l'écris il va arriver un drame
il va
audoul Marine Le Pen à la condamné un
les intimidations de l'extrême droite
contre le maire de Saint-Brévin on vous
a quand même reproché au rassemblement
national de pas vous être levé ou pas
tous levés vous vous souvenez c'était la
semaine dernière dans l'hémicycle
c'était à tout le mois de maladresse
vous le regrettez ça
mais on parle de quoi véritablement on
parle d'atteinte contre la démocratie on
parle de violence on parle de menaces
contre des élus ce qui s'est passé à
Saint-Brévin c'est gravissime moi je
suis très inquiet de ce climat
aujourd'hui qui vise à la fois nos
institutions qui visent les responsables
politiques qui visent aussi puisqu'il
faut en parler il y a un ans sauvagement
qui gangrène la société française là on
parle de la violence contre les élus
mais la violence mais bien sûr
encore une fois
je ne suis pas d'extrême droite si ça
voulait me dire voilà
je préfère que ce soit très clair nous
nous condamnons tous les groupuscules
quel qu'il soit qu'il soit d'extrême
gauche qu'il soit d'extrême droite qui
soit d'extrême centre qui agite et qui
font de la violence leur seul programme
politique on en est là aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a plus de débats
publics possibles je rappelle que la
démocratie c'est la confrontation des
idées des idées et des convictions la
représentation nationale devait se lever
c'est on fait aussi quel groupe
rassemblement national ne sait pas levée
ça vous le reconnaissez est-ce que vous
le regrettez on va pas passer le débat
là-dessus croyez moi il y a une manille
depuis quelques mois quelques semaines
qui est une dictature du assis debout
pour déterminer qui est dans le camp du
Bien qui applaudit qui se met debout qui
est dans le camp du mal qui décide de se
de renoncer à se plier à cette dictature
voilà encore une fois les responsables
excusez-moi
l'État qui a abandonné ce maire l'État
qui abandonnait ce maire comme l'état
aussi et comparaison n'est pas raison
avait abandonné un professeur de la
République qui ensuite a été décapité il
faut s'en rappeler c'est l'État qui
respecte exactement
de cette cada ce centre d'accueil
demandeur d'asile absolument qui va donc
être transféré pour leur c'est pas
changer ce projet près d'une école là
encore ça n'a pas alimenté le fait que
notamment il y a un conseiller un élu
départemental représentant de
départementale du RN qui était dans ces
manifs sachant que il y avait déjà pas
mal de tension ça vous l'assumez
complètement mais il faut distinguer le
débat démocratique moi je suis
extrêmement opposé à l'accueil de
migrants et l'installation de centre de
demandeurs d'asile pour autant je
condamne de la manière la plus ferme
toutes les agressions physiques toutes
les intimidations qui n'ont pas leur
place en démocratie mais je vous dis
encore une fois si vous assimilez et si
vous criminalisez l'opposition
démocratique sur des convictions on peut
être opposé opposé à l'installation d'un
projet et au lien on peut condamner par
exemple
on peut être intimidation riposte mais
bien évidemment elles n'ont pas leur
place en démocratie en revanche le débat
politique il doit avoir lieu on peut
être à l'immigration massive on peut
aussi détestent on va revenir sur le
tweet de Jean-Luc Mélenchon mais on
reste sur Saint-Brevin d'abord de quoi
cette affaire est-elle le nom selon vous
d'abord réagir aux propos de mon voisin
il y a des mots il y a des déclarations
monsieur odule vient d'en faire puis il
y a des actes mardi dernier à l'occasion
des questions gouvernement à 4 reprises
des questions ont été adressées à la
première ministre sur la situation de ce
maire à 4 reprises tous les groupes de
l'Assemblée nationale se sont levés pour
rendre hommage à ce maire sauf un le
rassemblement national et s'il ne l'a
pas fait ça n'était pas pour ne pas
céder à une prétendue dictature c'est
parce qu'il est embarrassé le
rassemblement national et pourquoi
est-il parce que ce sont ses amis ce
sont des militants des responsables vous
l'avez dit le rassemblement national de
reconquête qui ont manifesté pour
interroger ce terme
et qui ont participé d'un climat
détestable insupportable qui est à
l'origine ensuite de l'incendie de son
domicile et du fait qu'il démissionne et
du fait que sa famille se retrouve dans
cette situation qui est un maire divers
droites pour
le préciser malgré tout ça ne change
rien au sujet et à la première
responsabilité c'est celle-ci c'est
celle de l'extrême droite et on voit que
le rassemblement national il la compagne
cette violence parce que au fond il
refuse de la condamner la deuxième
responsabilité ça n'est pas celle de
l'État c'est celle de ceux qui le dirige
c'est celle du gouvernement c'est le
gouvernement qui d'abord n'a rien dit et
il n'a pas rien dit pendant quelques
heures pendant quelques jours il n'a
rien dit pendant six semaines je
rappelle que quand monsieur Éric Zemmour
a été agressé dans la rue dans le
contexte de la dernière campagne
présidentielle en moins de 24 heures le
président de la République Emmanuel
Macron l'appelait pour lui manifester
son soutien là nous avons un maire dont
la vie et la famille sont menacées qui
est laissée seul mais bien sûr je le
reprends mais c'est pas l'argumentaire
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon ce sont des faits
et je crois que ça doit nous alerter
parce que quand on laisse un élu de la
République seul ainsi quand ensuite on
va banaliser ce qui s'est
que le déménagement et l'extension de ce
centre d'accueil demandeur d'asile qui
devait alors accueillir à côté d'une
école il est vrai Sandy demandeur
d'asile suscite l'inquiétude de quelques
parents d'élèves de l'école de la pierre
ses parents se rendent rapidement compte
que et bien ils n'auront pas gain de
cause dans la dans la commune s'ils ne
font pas appel à des renforts c'est là
qu'il se tourne vers effectivement des
renforts politiques qu'ils savent à qui
à leur cause en l'occurrence le délégué
départemental du rassemblement national
vous l'avez dit Gautier boucher de
Loire-Atlantique et également des
éluroconquêtes en particulier le
candidat au législatif Bernard Jamin qui
avait écrit un livre au titre plutôt
éloquent Kalak la mer des batailles à
partir de là se met en place une
escalade dans la sémantique et la
rhétorique employée et dès la première
manifestation du mois de décembre
j'entends à la tribune dans cette
manifestation effectivement parrainée
par Gilbert Collard
des personnalités des deux groupes issus
de groupuscules externes des propos de
type nous ne voulons pas à côté de notre
col de notre école pardonnez-moi
l'expression d'un CVC centre de viol
collectif voilà la tonalité des propos
dès le mois de décembre dernier s'ensuit
effectivement des carences et des
défaillances manifestes dont le maire de
Saint-Brevin a fait état de la part de
la part des autorités dont il n'a pas
dans la sous-préfecture de Saint-Nazaire
en effet dont il n'a pas
reçu le soutien qu'il aurait espéré une
gendarmerie qui a probablement un
certain moment minimisé l'étendue des
menaces et on en arrive à la solution à
la situation d'aujourd'hui il y a quand
même une porosité pour bien comprendre
entre le rassemblement national dans la
manifestation et ce continuum de
violence ou pas les propos qui sont
tenus sur scène tels que l'expression
audio que je vous ai rapporté non pas
été prononcé par gothiboucher en
revanche ce que je peux dire c'est que
ce jour-là à côté donc de ce futur cada
Gauthier boucher monte sur scène et dit
qu'effectivement
il y aura il appuiera l'opposition
askada aussi longtemps qu'il le faudra
par la suite consignes a été donné au
rassemblement national il est vrai il
faut être honnête sur ce point de se
désengager et de préconiser l'issue d'un
référendum local qui semblait être une
des solutions pour sortir par l'eau de
cette spirale de violence et c'est dans
un second temps et le climat était
installé climat qui a qui a pesé sur le
maire de Saint-Brévin mais aussi sur sa
famille donc ce soir il est à Matignon
manifestement il ne reviendra pas sur sa
décision et je la comprends le centre
d'accueil vous êtes élu de la République
il doit être transféré près de cette
école c'est une forme quoi de nécessité
maintenant politique
je vais vous répondre tout à l'heure on
a eu un débat sur la justice on nous
disait il manque des places de prison
10000 places de prison prévue sur le
donc c'est le Miss de la justice du pont
Moretti qu'il a annoncé bon
vous savez que pour avoir des places de
prison il faut l'accord des mers donc
tout le monde veut des places de prison
en plus mais les élus locaux n'en
veulent pas
une prison à côté de son école à côté de
son collège à côté de sa maison personne
donc si vous voulez c'est insoluble
parce que quand j'ai un soluble comme ça
a priori moi je pense qu'il y a un
travail mais là ce projet
absolument mais l'idée du référendum en
fait ça je l'avais lu mais la chose est
que le maire a décidé de consulter il a
aussi des obligations et puis après tout
il a aussi été élu de manière
démocratique pour faire des choses ou
pas il n'est pas obligé en tant que mère
de consulter la population une fois
qu'il a été élu je veux dire ce que je
ce que moi en tout cas moi ma réponse à
tout ça c'est que il va falloir où on
change de doctrine ou je le redis voir
il va arriver un drame c'est quoi la
doctrine c'est de renforcer la sécurité
sur les élus pourquoi je dis sur les
élus c'est que on a tellement tout
banalisé une effigie du président de la
République brûlée c'est rigolo d'accord
il trouve ça drôle il y a des gens qui
trouvent ça drôle c'est il se lève le
matin ils vont brûler une effigie je
trouve ça rigolo je leur demande si tu
vois ta mère ou ton père ou ta femme ou
ton enfant brûler en effigieuse que
c'est guignolesque non c'est très très
grave la chose c'est que je pense que
nous ne pouvons plus être des élus comme
les autres parce que vous avez peur
vous-même non moi j'ai pas peur parce
que je vais vous dire j'ai pas peur j'ai
été agressé pendant ma campagne je me
suis défendue et on m'a reproché de Me
défendu et la faire a été classée sans
suite vous imaginez j'ai été agressé je
suis une femme j'avais fait un bon homme
de 2 mètres qui pesait 120 kg et c'est
moi c'est moi sur les réseaux sociaux
qui était la cible de un député à les
filles pas monsieur vanille bien sûr
mamie une cible sur le dos la semaine
dernière j'ai reçu plein de menaces de
mort sur les réseaux je ne regarde pas
les réseaux sociaux de quoi vous parlez
non non je parle de je parle de la
l'attaque sur les réseaux sociaux
d'Aymeric Caron le truc c'est que
vous avez menacé de mort vous rendez
compte de la vous faites l'illustration
d'une sorte de surenchère
c'est que tout est banalisé ça
maintenant on met quelqu'un aussi vous
dire on le jette en peinture sur les
réseaux sociaux et tout le monde trouve
ça normal ce que je vous dire c'est que
c'est pas banal à attaquer à nos mères
quelqu'un un élu surtout quand on est
soi-même un élu c'est pas normal alors
qu'est-ce qu'on fait la question est-ce
qu'il faut bien dire que les menaces
elles touchent tous les élus hein c'est
pas la peur c'est que je vous dis je
l'ai dit il y a 2 ans je le vois chaque
jour et aller parler avec tous les élus
locaux bien sûr mais on n'a pas peur
pour nous on a peur pour nos familles
évidemment est-ce qu'il va se passer
c'est une démission collective c'est que
tout le monde va dire bon écoutez
maintenant et reprenez l'écharpe prenez
faites comme vous voulez et trouvons
tout ça drôle marrant alors c'est pas
grave
bon de l'hémicycle et puis vous êtes
aussi responsable Paul vanille à la
France insoumise on a théorisé la
spiritualité dans l'hémicycle comme une
forme de de catalyseur de cette violence
dans la société non est-ce que tout ce
qu'on a pu entendre je vous pose la
question de violent et c'est pas moi qui
le dit dans l'hémicycle des bancs de des
insoumis pendant la réforme des
retraites est-ce que pour vous ça
nourrit cette violence ou est-ce qu'au
contraire c'est la catalyse en
l'occurrence si vous le dites vous vous
reprenez ces arguments et quand nous
parlons de la conflictualité nous
parlons de la conflictualité des
arguments la politique elle est le lieu
en effet de l'opposition des arguments
il va y avoir un ballon un problème
et vous le savez il s'est excusé mais
d'ailleurs le terme qu'il a employé il a
employé compris un Syndicate comme
Bernard Thibault quelques semaines plus
tard a indiqué qu'il pouvait comprendre
ce qu'exprimait ce mot mal choisi à
propos des morts au travail qui se
comptent par dizaines et dizaines dans
notre pays parce que il y a une
difficulté c'est d'abord un on mélange
tout vous l'avez fait chers collègues
vous avez mélangé beaucoup de situations
vous avez parlé vous avez fait des
vocation qui ne sont pas très facile
vous avez mélangé
la confrontation des arguments et la
violence physique qui est absolument
condamnable et qui ne doit jamais être
accepté et tolérer donc d'abord il ne
faut pas il ne faut pas tout mélanger et
puis rien mais si je crois que je crois
que je crois que vous l'avez fait et
puis moi je vais vous dire la solution
la solution la solution c'est plus de
démocratie notre pays est malade de ces
institutions République qui sont bloqués
elles sont on le voit mais on en fait on
en fait d'ailleurs ici collectivement je
pense l'expérience quotidienne elle ne
marche plus y compris on a une assemblée
qui est inédite dans sa composition dans
son fonctionnement mais c'est bloqué ça
ne marche plus les aspirations du peuple
français aussi diverses qu'elles soient
ne sont plus traduites par le mécanisme
c'est l'urgence l'urgence elle est dans
une refondation complète de nos
institutions qui redonne du pouvoir qui
redistribue le pouvoir
avec peut-être en tout cas avec le fait
de confier au peuple français le soin
par une constituante en effet dans
délibéré en effet de confronter des
arguments et de choisir des institutions
revigorer qui nous permettent de sortir
de parce qu'en effet l'heure est grave
et nous nous disons plus de démocratie
plus d'arguments plus de solutions
raisonnables et raisonnée pour et bien
trancher les grandes questions qui se
présentent avec tous les éléments sur le
recours au peuple ça vous aide d'accord
avec la France insoumise j'imagine il
faut plus de démocratie pour revenir on
est totalement proposé pour essayer
d'apaiser et effectivement pour
l'apaisement il y a deux choses la
première c'est éviter de jeter de
l'huile sur le feu et la France
insoumise à la violence dans son ADN
l'expression politique de la France
insoumise attise la violence dans notre
pays il faut le dire il faut le redire
encore une fois le débat sur la réforme
des retraites que nous avons vécu
j'allais dire subit a été un torrent
d'injures d'outrans de violence et ça a
des répercussions dans le pays
évidemment sur des éléments les plus
radicaux qui prennent ces mots pour
argent comptant et qui vont s'en prendre
ensuite que ce soit à des militants à
des élus à la famille de Madame Macron
donc très clairement il faut que ça
s'arrête et que Monsieur Mélenchon
arrête de se jouer en petit Staline en
petite agitateur du peuple en permanence
je rappelle qu'il avait quand même
appelé en découdre appelé en découdre
notamment entre entre
la réforme
Monsieur Mélenchon Mélenchon qui est un
fauteuil de la violence qui est un
fauteuil de trouble voilà aujourd'hui la
France insoumise il faut le dire porte
une grave responsabilité ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
la dissuasion la dissuasion pour tous
ceux qui osent s'attaquer à nos
institutions à un élu ou plus
généralement à nos concitoyens qui sont
victimes pour renforcer les sanctions et
que les peines soient appliquées une
bonne fois pour toute quand on touche un
cheveu quand les plaintes sont déposées
excusez-moi elles ne sont pas piquées
parce qu'elles sont pas dissuasives et
vous le savez très bien si je prends mon
cas personnel je pense que nous tous
nous tous nous sommes tous resp
politique et nous avons que ce soit sur
les réseaux sociaux nous avons
régulièrement pour pas dire
quotidiennement des insultes des menaces
de mort j'en ai un certain nombre j'ai
eu des agressions dans l'espace public
etc ça a été la plupart du temps classé
sans suite il faut qu'il y ait des
suites il faut qu'il y ait des sanctions
qui tombent et il faut une bonne fois
pour toute que les photos de cours des
réseaux sociaux c'est très compliqué ce
que si ils sont un élu ils seront punis
justement on va on va essayer de parler
de l'autre affaire puisque il y a ce
télescopage aujourd'hui avec ce
tabassage du petit neveu Jean-Baptiste
trogneux d'Emmanuel Macron je vais vous
montrer une vidéo qui circule sur Tik
Tok parce que ce nom là il existe il est
déjà ciblé depuis longtemps et c'est
chocolateries à la fois à Amiens mais
aussi au Touquet également regardez ce
qu'on peut trouver sur Tik Tok
yo
[Musique]
voilà ça c'est l'ultra droite
quand on écoute les spécialistes des
réseaux sociaux il vous disent
aujourd'hui que ce nom là notre oignon
dans la fashosphère
dans le chez les conspirationsnistes il
est jeté chez les complotistes déjà
depuis des mois
comment on fait contre ça effectivement
cette cette rumeur transforme en
l'occurrence à l'endroit de Brigitte
Macron que donc on a délibérément voulu
faire passer pour un pour un homme et
surnommé donc Jean-Michel trogneux du
nom de son frère elle court depuis des
mois elle a été bien repérée par
effectivement les observateurs du
conspirationnisme en France et elle a
cours sur un certain nombre de
plateformes d'extrême droite de site
extrême droite je peux j'en tiens
pourquoi par exemple le fait que cette
information ait été relayée par le site
français de souche
c'est la raison pour laquelle
effectivement à Amiens l'usine de la
famille trogneux a été pris pour cible
avant même que Jean-Baptiste trogneux
n'était été agressé par ce groupe de 8
individus la lumière reste à faire sur
cette question 3 3
mais sur le si je me place maintenant
sur le terrain des solutions Dominique
Faure la ministre délégué
la création d'un centre d'analyse et de
lutte contre les atteinte envers les
élus ce n'est pas anodin parce que on
voit bien la chaîne qui se dessine Kalak
Saint-Brevin aujourd'hui on sent bien
que ces groupes d'ultra-droits de
pousser des ailes demain c'est peut-être
bellabre dans l'Indre dans le maire
Laurent Laroche est particulièrement
inquiet à 7h et dont l'épouse même a
déjà été présenté pour l'implantation
effectivement le vote par son conseil
municipal municipal de l'installation
d'un centre d'accueil de vaincuir 38
demandeurs d'asile donc on voit bien la
chaîne qui dessine Kalak était la mère
des batailles ça n'a pas vocation à
s'arrêter dans l'esprit de ces militants
d'ultra-droite
par conséquent un centre d'analyse de ce
type aurait vocation auraient je parle
aux conditionnel la cartographie ce qui
est l'itinérance de groupuscule
l'extrême droite qui ne viennent pas à
chaque fois des communes parce qu'il
faut bien le rappeler ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas les administrer et toujours
qui à l'origine des violences contre les
à l'endroit de leur mère ça peut c'est
peut-être le cas mais ce n'est pas
toujours le cas et lorsque des projets
impopulaires de cada mais ça peut être
également des projets environnementaux
effectivement l'implantation des
éoliennes en l'occurrence les
mégapassins bien évidemment et bien
lorsqu'il y a des projets impopulaires
mais qui correspondent à une politique
diligée par le plus hautes autorités de
l'État et bien c'est maire attendent
effectivement un soutien de la part des
autorités
le chocolatier franchement franchement
quoi exprimé
est tout à fait approprié parce qu'il
nous dit une chose fondamentale c'est
que toutes les violences sont qu'on a et
quand Jean-Luc Mélenchon élu à l'époque
candidat à l'élection présidentielle et
la cible pour la deuxième fois d'un
projet d'attentat qui vise à le tuer
faut monter par un gendarme militant de
l'extrême droite il est insupportable
d'apprendre qu'il n'a pas été informé et
de ne voir aucune solidarité être
exprimée à son égard parce que il faut
exprimer de la solidarité pour le neveu
d'Emmanuel Macron qui est la cible de
violence est inacceptable mais toutes
les violences sont condamnables pourquoi
cette ironie pourquoi moquer Jean-Luc
Mélenchon lorsque lorsqu'il dit
lorsqu'il découvre imaginez-le c'est sa
vie dont il s'agit qu'il a été la cible
d'un deuxième projet d'attentat qui vise
à le tuer pourquoi ironiser sur sa
réaction et pourquoi se satisfaire du
silence du silence du silence
assourdissant parce qu'il n'y a eu en
dehors des rangs de la France insoumise
et de la nupestre personne pour dire
solidarité
cette violence là qui s'exercer contre
lui et il y a toujours un mais c'est
tout et on peut tout à fait distinguer
les sujets mais simplement pourquoi les
mettre ensemble c'est tout à ce stade du
débat et puis on t'a terminé juste par
un sujet on n'aura pas le temps de
réagir parce que on a on a préparé un
sujet parce que derrière tout ça c'est
évidemment le président de la République
qui est qui est visé ça n'a rien à voir
votre sujet de dialyse mais on voit
qu'il y a de la tension dans le pays il
y a d'attention entre les politiques on
sent bien que l'ultra droite l'ultra
gauche tout ça se renvoie un petit peu
la faute
ce sentiment violent c'est un peu de
chaos parfois ça nourrit aussi d'autres
d'autres violences qui nous parfois en
fait ce qui est ce qui est étonnant
est-ce que ce sentiment alors peut-être
avec une forme de distance aussi puisque
je chercheur mais pas commentateur
politique mais je j'ai l'impression
quand même qu'on parle d'un phénomène
d'important qui est celui de la
polarisation la polarisation de la vie
politique et cette polarisation à un
moment donné produit de la violence et
donc c'est de la violence verbale
aujourd'hui c'est de la violence
physique de plus en plus mais l'enjeu
central c'est celui de la démocratie et
de ce point de vue là je vois un certain
nombre de convergences avec le sujet que
je traite qui est le celui du djihadisme
c'est d'une part la déformation que
produisent les réseaux sociaux qui
amplifient considérablement à un moment
donné des phénomènes et qui permettent
de diffuser des mots d'ordre qui
permettent de mobiliser un certain
nombre d'individus qui eux soient sont
prêts à tout soit en tout cas sont des
militants qui qui n'ont pas peur
d'intimider par la violence et la
violence produit des effets politiques
très forts que ce soit de l'autocensure
que ce soit à un moment donné une une
forme de distance avec un certain nombre
de sujets mais enjeux central de tout ça
ça reste la démocratie et c'est pour ça
que je pense que faut faire attention
dans les commentaires à pas jeter le
bébé avec l'eau du bain alors le signal
que malheureusement on n'a pas le temps
de vous montrer le sujet parce qu'on va
terminer par ce tour de table évidemment
c'est la personne du président de la
République qui est visé avec avec ce
petit neveu de de Brigitte Macron il y a
une haine qui est totalement viscérale
on a comparé certaines images avec les
prédécesseurs est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment qu'il y a un cap qui est qui
est franchi ou finalement la violence
contre le chef de l'État a toujours été
là et soit détesté à leur époque on se
rappelle de Nicolas Sarkozy on se
rappelle de Hollande plus récemment on
se rappelle encore de François
Mitterrand je dirais non à l'histoire je
pense de la Cinquième République fait
que et je l'ai je l'ai pareil je
l'écrive je le redis c'est aussi la
fonction qui avait selon moi sauf qu'on
a changé d'époque ce que je crois c'est
qu'on a changé d'époque et que les
réseaux sociaux ont de manière viscérale
fondamentalement changer le rapport à la
violence les gens se pensent dans un jeu
vidéo c'est à dire on n'est plus dans le
réel vous pensez que le combat perdu
d'avance il y a des règles au niveau
européenne ou sinon il y a des règles
sur la haine en ligne des lois qui ont
été votées c'est David contre Goliath
mais ce que je crois moi ce que je crois
c'est la responsabilité des élus parce
que quand on est élu on peut pas se
comporter comme un lambda on ne peut pas
on a une trop grande responsabilité un
mandat c'est trop important on ne peut
pas dire la police tue on ne peut pas
dire minorer des choses on est contre un
cada donc on va tout brûler c'est plus
possible est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
c'est ça le de retrouver des solutions
en commun est-ce qu'un consensus à
l'Assemblée est possible pour au fond
vous défendre presque physiquement pour
trouver naturel ça devrait être naturel
c'est notre bien commun la démocratie
évidemment après sur le président de la
République moi je distingue totalement
les attaques incalifiables innommables
du comportement du président de la
République qui est le premier à avoir
une attitude maltraitante vis-à-vis de
son peuple et notamment le premier un
autre débat régulièrement
la situation et le rôle des responsables
politiques c'est d'apaiser et pour
apaiser il faut plus de démocratie et il
faut redonner aux Français la clé pour
au fond de leurs institutions sinon nous
n'y arriverons pas malheureusement
s'arrêter là évidemment c'est un débat
qui ne fait que commencer on en est
peut-être sur LCP à notre cinquième
débat sur la violence contre les élus
cette affaire est grave il faut il faut
en parler on verra comment tout ça
débouche concrètement ou pas merci
beaucoup la violence je pense que ça
doit être le dernier mot merci à vous et
merci à vous Antoine auberdov pour
toutes les détails de terrain vous
restez avec moi Hugo Micheron dans une
dizaine de minutes exactement les partis
pris de nos affranchis ce soir jean-y
Beaudot va revenir sur la condamnation
de Nicolas Sarkozy dans l'affaire des
écoutes premiers ancien président
condamné à de la prison ferme le regard
d'Isabelle Lasserre sur la fin d'un
tabou la livraison d'avions de chasse à
l'Ukraine peut-on vraiment y croire et
puis Bourbon express avec Marco polonais
ce soir ce Shadow cabinet des
républicains qui tournent un peu à la
risée mais d'abord on va se plonger ger
dans votre livre la colère et l'oubli
chez Gallimard qui vient combler un
manque important fondamental même à la
recherche sur le djihadisme en écrire
une histoire européenne pourquoi ça
manquait et que dit ce manque on va
d'abord voir tout cela dans l'invitation
de Stéphanie Despierre et puis on en
parle ensemble juste après
[Musique]
si on vous invite Hugo Micheron c'est
parce que vous racontez avec pédagogie
comment 30 ans l'Europe est devenue une
cible du djihadisme et un foyer de
terrorisme dans votre livre vous
démontrez que le djihadisme fonctionne
par vague avec des marées hautes
synonyme d'attaque meurtrière et
démarrer basse des périodes de repli les
sociétés européennes elles alternent
entre la colère juste après les
attentats et l'oubli pendant les
accalmies une erreur qui conduit à une
mauvaise lecture du djihadisme et si on
approche uniquement sous le plan du
terrorisme en fait on approche des
filières en attendant qu'il y ait un un
attentat ou une préparation d'un acte
caractérisé ce qu'on ne comprend pas
c'est que le djihadisme en tant
qu'idéologie produit des effets
politiques etc et donc si on ne
s'intéresse qu'aux attentats finalement
on vient à la fin du film et moi ce que
je propose de faire dans ce livre c'est
finalement de regarder tout le film avec
les sous-titres et c'est à dire un
moment donné de se poser la question de
qu'est-ce que le djihadisme en dehors
simplement de de ces attentats et de ses
différentes vagues qui viennent et puis
qui repartent chercheurs professeur à
Sciences Po après avoir ausculté le
phénomène en France voudrait c'est une
histoire du djihadisme européen il y a
eu l'époque des vétérans de la guerre
Russo afghane et de la guerre civile
algérienne qui après avoir combattu très
loin d'ici s'installe en Europe surtout
en Grande-Bretagne puis il y a l'air des
pionniers dans les années 2000 où
l'idéologie djihadiste s'implante dans
plusieurs capitales du continent pour
vous les attentats de Madrid en 2004
marquent un tournant l'Europe et
désormais une cible enfin il y a les
djihadistes autochtones à partir de 2010
ils ont grandi en Europe ils seront les
auteurs de la terrible vague d'attentats
qui commencent à Paris en 2015 les
places fortes du terrorisme sont Londres
Bruxelles Copenhague Amsterdam Toulouse
dans votre ouvrage vous dessinez la
carte de ces quartiers spécifiques fief
de soldats du djihad depuis 2012 6000
européens ont rejoint la Syrie pour
combat tre d'après vous le facteur le
plus déterminant ce n'est pas la
pauvreté mais la présence de salafistes
dans ces quartiers aujourd'hui le
djihadisme européen est dans une phase
de sommeil mais la menace est toujours
là alors Hugo Micheron nos dirigeants en
ont-ils pleinement conscience
réponse est-ce qu'on n'est pas déjà un
peu dans l'oubli voir dans le déni dans
cette phase un peu de reflux qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui c'est une bonne
question évidemment il m'appartient pas
forcément des d'y répondre pour
l'ensemble des dirigeants européens ce
qui est sûr c'est que le niveau de
préoccupation et c'est normal on
comprend bien en démocratie on a vu un
certain nombre de sujets aussi qui sont
importants dont on a parlé avant
la tendance est plutôt qu'un sujet
chasse l'autre en revanche sur ce sujet
là celui du djihadisme il faut du suivi
sur le long terme ce que j'ai essayé de
faire c'est justement de produire un
diagnostic qui dont on produit en fait
un schéma explicatif sur 30 ans et ça je
suis pas sûr que tout le monde l'est en
tête justement c'est étonnant cette
histoire européenne du djihadisme qui
n'avait pas été écrite jusqu'à présent
c'est désormais chose faite mais que
signifie au fond ce manque là
c'est un sujet compliqué il y a souvent
eu des explications rapides un peu à
l'emporte-pièce on a eu tendance à
réduire le djihadisme à l'horreur des
attentats c'est évidemment une partie
significative mais c'est plutôt la
conséquence
il y a beaucoup d'appréhension c'est un
sujet difficile politiquement
extrêmement lourd extrêmement chargé et
puis c'est un sujet qui n'est pas récent
mais dans ces matérialisations
dramatiques c'est à dire les attentats
qui est récent donc on a une génération
de chercheurs qui n'a peut-être pas été
suffisamment formé en suffisamment grand
nombre et je pense que ça c'est un un
des aspects très important vous voyez
qu'on a du mal encore à comprendre que
le djihadisme c'est une idéologie
politique ou religieuse radicale bien
au-delà de des passages à l'acte violent
qui n'en sont finalement que la
conséquence oui je dirais que c'est vrai
que en fait il y a une par rapport à
cette question je me suis rendu compte
que quand on parle avec les gens très
rapidement ils comprennent que c'est une
idéologie qui a pas que les attentats
que tout ça évolue etc donc c'est pas
quelque chose de compliqué à comprendre
mais en réalité ce qui pêche c'est que
souvent il ne comprennent pas ce qu'il y
a derrière une idéologie moi ce que je
montre est-ce que ce qui me semble très
important de comprendre dans le débat
public c'est qu'une idéologie c'est des
choses très concrètes les idées quand
les premiers djihadistes débarquent dans
les années 90 à Londres ou à Bruxelles
ou à Copenhague par exemple ils arrivent
avec des idées très très claires sur ce
qu'est la démocratie et surtout ce qu'il
faut empêcher que l'islam devienne en
Europe et ils vont tout de suite mettre
la pression alors au début c'est sur des
tout petits groupes c'est des dizaines
de personnes ils vont mettre la pression
sur des musulmans leur disant tu as pas
intérêt à t'intégrer ce que tu joues si
tu deviens citoyen britannique si tu
adhères en fait à ce système
démocratique et ses valeurs et tout ce
que tu joues c'est c'est ton salut c'est
ta foi c'est donc des questions
religieuses mais avec un impact
politique très concret et alors au début
ça ressemblait à rien c'était 10
individus 15 individus 20 individus à
Londres très médiatique qui est en fait
provoqué donc on les a pris peut-être de
haut on les a pas pris au sérieux en
tout cas la réalité c'est que derrière
en fait ils montaient des sites internet
ils créent des des groupes d'individus
qui allaient à un moment donné monter
des prédications ils allaient structurer
ça et donc quand ces individus ont fini
par être condamné après les attentats du
11 septembre les attentats de Londres
etc parce qu'ils étaient impliqués dans
ces attentats en fait ils avaient formé
la génération d'après et en fait c'est
ce djihadisme en dehors des attentats
c'est avant tout des idées qui ont des
impacts très concrets
de comprendre c'est qu'il se réduit pas
à la capacité de nuire des organisations
dont il se réclament puisque daesh et
maintenant un peu réduite et Al-Qaïda
aussi expliquez-nous pourquoi on peut
pas comprendre le phénomène français du
djihadin sans passer par l'échelle
l'élargissement de la focale à l'Europe
parce qu'en fait alors ce que j'ai voulu
faire c'est repartir de chiffres
concrets objectifs parce que le débat
est tellement finalement polarisé sur
ces sujets qu'il faut prendre des
éléments factuels qui sont
incontestables ce schéma là c'est les
6000 européens qui sont partis
on a on a remis les principales villes
qui ont subi en Europe des attentats
meurtriers et puis ensuite sur les 6000
dont vous parliez des parts pour le
djihad en pourcentage de la population
en Syrie donc on a les on a les
pourcentages les proportions par pays
donc on voit donc sur ces 6000 si on
fait le découpage ça fait en 32% que ça
fait 2000 français qui ont rejoint
ensuite on a la Grande-Bretagne à peu
près 1000 l'Allemagne à peu près 1000 un
petit peu plus vous avez ensuite la
Belgique autour de 600 vous avez les
Pays-Bas autour de 300 la Suède autour
de 300 et puis vous avez 180 en en
Danemark et à peu près 200 ans parce que
le gros des départ c'est les pays du
Nord scandale en fait là vous avez les
chiffres les volumes dans l'absolu mais
si vous ramenez par rapport à la
population ces chiffres sont deviennent
énormes en proportion en tout cas bien
plus important pour le Danemark il y a
une toute petite population pour la
Belgique et pour la Suède donc
la France pas le même modèle de laïcité
le même rapport à l'immigration à
l'histoire coloniale notamment et oui
tout à fait pour ce qui est des pays
scandinaves pardon ils ont ils ont pas
d'histoire coloniale ils ont ce sont des
pays qui ont une histoire de
l'immigration qui est totalement
différente de celle de la France de
l'Allemagne de la Belgique ou de la
Grande-Bretagne c'est pas une
immigration de travail c'est une
immigration qui arrivait tardivement
dans les années 90 plutôt des personnes
réfugiées qui cherchaient à fuir des
zones de conflits et les violences
systémiques qui subissaient là-bas donc
qu'est-ce que pourquoi le djihadisme a
pris dans cette environnement par
ailleurs des sociétés très égalitaires
sur plan j'ai eu l'occasion de visiter
un certain nombre de de de
l'équivalent des cités chaudes danoises
on est sur des standards qui sont
proches de la zone PA partenaires de
classe moyenne en France à tous les
niveaux c'est ça
quelque chose si l'on veut parler de
djihadisme
il faut aller plus loin que la question
socio-économique parce que les nations
continuaient de zoomer sur cette carte
qu'on verrait c'est qu'en fait les
départs se concentrent en fait dans
certaines villes puis dans certains
quartiers en fait dans certains
environnements humains et ces villes se
sont pas les villes les plus pauvres
d'Europe ou des pays en question ce sont
pas les villes où il y a la plus forte
population musulmane c'est pas les pays
les villes pardon où il y a la plus
forte population
bec alors en fait on a plusieurs modèles
donc si vous prenez seulement le critère
socio-économique vous n'expliquez pas le
phénomène si vous prenez seulement le
l'analyse migratoire vous n'analisez pas
le phénomène donc il faut aller au-delà
si vous voulez des grands discours qui
vous disent que tout ça c'est une
réponse à l'injustice évidemment c'est
en partie la propagande de daesh qui dit
en fait on est légitime parce que vous
êtes injuste et donc c'est pour ça que
j'ai voulu aller plus loin et le point
de départ il permet de faire émerger un
élément c'est que toutes les villes qui
vont fournir la quasi-totalité des
départs pour la Syrie dans les années
2010 donc au moment de daesh c'est en
fait des villes où se sont implantées
des vétérans du Jihad afghan et du dji
dans les années 90 donc il y a une
géographie et derrière il y a une
histoire du djihadisme européen et ça
c'est très important de le comprendre
parce que ça vous permet d'expliquer des
cas comme Hulk Hulk c'est là dans la sur
la carte c'est au sud de l'Allemagne à
Ulm qui est une ville qui est
l'antimolenbeek si vous voulez c'est une
ville qui est plutôt florissante il y a
très peu de chômage dans le sud de
l'Allemagne entouré de petites PME qui
emploient beaucoup de monde dans les
nouvelles technologies etc ville
étudiant par ailleurs pourtant une c'est
le lieu de la première filiale la
première cellule djihadiste allemande et
ça a donné toute une génération de
djihadistes dont l'un d'entre eux va
être l'Européen le plus haut gradé
soudage ce que je veux dire c'est que
vous pouvez pas expliquer une et
Molenbeek en même temps qui est l'opposé
Molenbeek la ville la commune populaire
du de voilà avec qui cumulent les
inégalités les handicaps vous pouvez pas
expliquer l'une et l'autre si vous
comprenez pas que l'élément commun c'est
que dans les deux cas vous allez dans
les années 90 des prédicateurs
issus des fonds du Jihad afghan qui se
sont installés qui ont formé des
instituts qui ont formé des jeunes et
qui ont cherché à diffuser leurs idées
et ça on continue parce qu'on a peu de
temps alors l'Italie imperméable au
djihadisme
n'est pas imperméable pas plus que les
autres pays sont permables je pense que
c'est important de le le comprendre
l'Italie c'est vrai que quand on regarde
les chiffres des départs il y a 11
italiens 11 c'est très peu qui ont
rejoint les groupes djihadistes en Syrie
alors si on prend le nombre de gens qui
résident en Italie les résidents on en a
un peu plus plutôt de l'ordre de la
centaine mais c'est très faible même
comparé par exemple la Suède c'est
beaucoup plus faible et la raison c'est
parce que l'Italie a été touché par le
même phénomène dans les années 90 que
que ces autres pays mais par contre
est-ce que c'est par chance est-ce que
c'est parce qu'il y a une réponse une
bonne compréhension une bonne analyse en
fait sur le fond mais les premiers
prédicateurs djihadistes ont été arrêtés
assez vite en fait et là il faudrait
multiplier un les recherches on en
manque comme je l'ai dit on manque
d'éléments d'objectivation mais ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'il y a une exception
italienne et que celle-là elle va nous
apprendre énormément de choses sur le
reste donc moi j'ai des éléments
d'hypothèses il va falloir le creuser
ce qui se passe ce qu'on veut savoir
qu'est-ce qui se passe maintenant
pendant cette période de marée basse
vous nous dites que les réseaux sont en
train de se reconstituer cette évolution
là est-ce qu'on la connaît est-ce qu'ils
ont la même idéologie mais ce qui change
les discours est-ce qu'ils évoluent et
comment déjà c'est plutôt rassurant
quand on est à marée basse parce que
c'est des moments typiquement où ils ont
moins de capacités opérationnelles
justement pour faire des attentats mais
ça ça veut pas dire qu'il faut se
relâcher donc faut regarder les
évolutions si vous voulez actuel c'est
déjà premier élément on a affaire à des
Européens ça il faut le comprendre donc
qu'est-ce que ça signifie ça veut dire
qu'il a fallu juste comme des Européens
s'il regarde la télé ils comprennent le
débat politique français ils comprennent
la polarisation politique comprenne que
là il y a des leviers sur quel eux ils
peuvent jouer éventuellement pour
diffuser des éléments pour recruter des
gens pour montrer que ce système est
terminé enfin ça va être ce genre
d'éléments le deuxième élément c'est
qu'ils ont assez peu de capacités
d'action seul c'est-à-dire que
historiquement si on regarde les grandes
phases djihadistes ils ont tout le temps
eu besoin d'un conflit à l'extérieur
très grave pour pouvoir émerger comme
une force c'est la guerre civile
syrienne décennies précédentes dans les
années 2000 c'est l'invasion l'Irak qui
va déstabiliser toute la région et avant
ça c'est l'Afghanistan d'État Liban qui
sortait de 15 ans de guerre et 50 guerre
civiles donc c'est c'est là où les
djihadistes quand ils se nichent sur une
crise préexistante donc il faut avoir ça
en tête c'est important quand on regarde
la géopolitique mondiale c'est qu'il
faut ouvrir les yeux c'est autant
d'ailleurs un ouvrage de recherche
extrêmement fouillé qu'un ouvrage
politique aussi qui qui nous alerte et
qui nous dit attention à ne pas tomber
dans l'oubli c'est passionnant il y a
aussi tout un une réflexion sur les
prisons sur les femmes qui forment un
changement de paradigme mais on n'a pas
le temps malheureusement d'en parler je
voudrais qu'on termine avec cette image
celle de Florence
berjo blackaire chercheuse au CNRS qui
est sous protection policière après ces
travaux de recherche sur les Frères
musulmans
alors moi je vous en parle d'autant plus
facilement que je la connais pas
personnellement et je voudrais laisser
totalement de côté la question de son
travail qu'on peut débattre dont on peut
débattre on peut être d'accord pas
d'accord etc il y a une question de
principe qui est fondamentale c'est que
aucun chercheur sur ce sujet n'arrête
menacé de mort quoi qu'on pense de son
travail c'est la seule chercheur en
France qui est sous protection policière
à l'heure actuelle et je pense que dans
une démocratie mature politiquement je
pense que c'est un point minimal
d'accord que dire que un chercheur par
ailleurs sur un sujet difficile n'a pas
être menacé dans l'exercice de ses
recherches et ça c'est ça fait aussi
écho un certain nombre de choses qu'on a
évoqué tout à l'heure nous sommes très
important la colère elle oublie
c'est-à-dire chez Gallimard c'est
absolument passionnant un peu effrayant
aussi et on y apprend énormément de
choses vous appelez d'ailleurs les
citoyens que nous sommes à nous
réveiller et même à nous entraîner à un
débat public plus fait qu'on vous restez
avec moi c'est l'heure des affranchis
leur parti pris vous vous faire réagir
on les accueille tout de suite
Isabelle laster la correspondante
diplomatique du figarocon voit
absolument partout mais aussi chez nous
on enfoir Isabelle Jean Reno de France
Info pour la politique on va parler de
Nicolas Sarkozy quelle condamnation dans
un instant mais on commence avec Bourbon
Express l'histoire de jour à l'Assemblée
nous est racontée ce soir par Marco
pommier bonsoir Marco bonsoir Myriam ce
soir je vous raconte l'histoire du
Shadow cabinet des républicains en bon
français le cabinet fantôme à l'heure de
quoi s'agit-il en fait c'est une sorte
de contre-gouvernement alternatif façon
Éric Ciotti c'est lui le président DLR
qui l'a composé ce Shadow cabinet il
s'est réuni pour la première fois ce
matin c'était au siège du parti une
réunion aux allures de conseil des
ministres avec la traditionnelle photo
de famille il ne manquait plus que les
dorures de l'Elysée Myriam alors à quoi
ressemble ce Shadow cabinet un chiffre
33 secrétaire nationaux au total un
casting à la notoriété très inégale sans
grande surprise en fait chacun reste
dans son domaine de prédilection Nadine
Morano je vous le donne en mille à
récupère le portefeuille de
l'immigration à Frédéric Pechenard
monsieur police obtient l'intérieur la
santé c'est pour le médecin juin et puis
Michel Barnier monsieur Europe lui
devient conseiller spécial pour les
affaires étrangères au final un
contre-gouvernement quasi paritaire 15
femmes pour 17 hommes et tout cela sous
la houlette de la secrétaire général du
parti à ni jeune var
c'est vous qui dirigez un peu en fait ce
contre gouvernement en fait vous êtes la
première ministre je crois qu'il faut
raisons garder ce Shadow cabinet c'est
la réunion de personnalité compétente
dans des domaines bien identifiés et je
suis chargée de la coordination de ce
travail je compte sur chacune de ces
personnalités pour animer le débat
politique pour enrichir notre ligne
idéologique de ces propositions et
préparer ainsi l'alternance
alors dans ce cabinet dans ce Shadow
cabinet tient un fantôme dont et bien
l'absence brille particulièrement ça ne
vous a pas échappé quinte d'Aurélien
Pradier l'électron libre des
républicains limogé de son poste de
numéro 2 pour ses prises de position sur
la réforme des retraites le trublion
Pradier était-il trop indiscipliné pour
intégrer le cabinet fantôme d'Éric
Ciotti on écoute le patron des
républicains
qui n'y sont pas mais il y a dans ce
Shadow cabinet des proches d'Aurélien
Pradier mais c'était pas du tout le
critère on n'est pas dans les équilibres
on est dans l'expression de la
compétence
et voilà voilà ambiance chez les
républicains exactement alors ce Shadow
cabinet c'est pas une révolution rien
d'inédit ce sont les Britanniques qui
ont inventé le concept au 19e siècle en
France d'autres s'y sont essayés
François Mitterrand Michel Alliot-Marie
mais aussi un certain Laurent Wauquiez
en 2018 bon à chaque fois c'est cabinet
fantôme ils ont une durée de vie
éphémère le succès il est pas vraiment
en rendez-vous le cabinet fantôme
d'érectionti lui il doit se réunir à
minima tous les mois certains
proposaient toutes les semaines mais
l'un des participants me confiait ce
matin le Conseil des Ministres s'est
déjà chiant pour les ministres alors si
on peut s'épargner ce genre de réunion
toutes les semaines tant mieux ça m'a
l'air très bien parti cette petite
affaire merci beaucoup Marco on enchaîne
avec vous Jean-Rémy Baudot politique
toujours ou plutôt politique et justice
la condamnation de Nicolas Sarkozy trois
ans de prison dont un NON ferme dans
l'affaire des écoutes on va d'abord
rappeler les faits c'est un dossier qui
a une dizaine d'années Nicolas Sarkozy
jugé coupable de corruption active et de
trafic d'influence la Justine le
condamne pour avoir promis en 2014 un
poste honorifique à un magistrat Gilbert
hazibert en échange d'informations
confidentielles sur une procédure dans
l'affaire Bettencourt à faire dans
laquelle d'ailleurs l'ancien président a
obtenu un non-lieu et aujourd'hui
Nicolas Sarkozy se pourvoit en cassation
oui alors autant dire que ça n'est pas
demain qu'on aura le dénouement de cette
affaire l'avocat de Nicolas Sarkozy
dénonce je cite une décision
particulièrement iniquée injuste douce
pour voie et après la cassation on
comprend qu'il y aura éventuellement
toutes les instances européennes
possibles c'est évidemment son droit
comme tout juste ici mais malgré les
recours malgré le recours aussi
éventuellement au bracelet électronique
cette condamnation selon moi est d'une
forme de tournant un ancien président
condamné à de la prison ferme c'est
inédit trois ans de privation de ces
droits civiques ça veut dire qu'il
n'aurait plus le droit de voter ça aussi
c'est fort ça veut dire que la justice
passe qu'il a été jugé comme un citoyen
presque ordinaire est-ce que c'est trop
sévère est-ce que c'est trop léger ça
n'est évidemment pas à moi de le dire
mais on peut se dire que la justice
n'épargne plus les puissants rappelant
que Jacques Chirac lui a aussi c'est
condamné à de la prison mais avec sursis
dans une affaire d'emploi effectif de la
Mairie de Paris donc ça veut dire que
les temps changent pour vous avec une
nouée les temps changent avec une
justice qui ne lâche pas même les
anciens présidents même quand ils ont
peut-être les meilleurs avocats de la
place on rappelle par ailleurs que le
marathon judiciaire n'est pas terminé
pour Nicolas Sarkozy il y a la faire
bigma Lyon il y a le dossier libyen
aussi les anciens présidents ne sont
plus à l'abri les temps changent les
pratiques aussi prenaient aujourd'hui
l'affaire Abad Damien Abad accusé de
viol et bien ce matin il a lui-même
demandé la levée de son immunité
parlementaire pour s'expliquer dans
cette affaire fut un temps disons-le
quand même l'immunité parlementaire
était un bouclier utilisé pendant le
plus longtemps possible et puis les
temps changent les réactions aussi
depuis ce matin très peu de réactions
politiques pour soutenir Nicolas Sarkozy
quelques rares voies à droite on parlait
de volonté d'humiliation il y a Olivier
Marleix le patron LR à l'assemblée qui a
dénoncé un acharnement mais on n'est
plus à l'époque on disait que la justice
était aux ordres que c'était les petits
juges que c'était de la justice
politique les temps changent la justice
passe on peut s'en féliciter c'est
peut-être dès le début d'une réponse à
cette petite musique du tout pourri et
si on revient quand même à la politique
les temps changent peut-être aussi sur
la politique le faible nombre de
réactions montre peut-être aussi que
Nicolas Sarkozy
après avoir dirigé incarné maîtrisé il a
désormais divisé la droite et peut-être
que certains chez l'air ne verrez pas
d'un mauvais œil qui sort définitivement
du jeu grâce à la justice
j'aurais mis Baudot merci j'en réuni
allez on termine avec vous Isabelle le
Royaume-Uni et les Pays-Bas qui
proposent une coalition internationale
pour livrer à l'Ukraine des avions de
combat FC est-ce que ça veut dire que le
tabou tombe et qu'on va le faire alors
oui non il est tombé ça c'est sûr depuis
le début de l'année pour les chars
lourds pour les avions de chasse s'il
n'est tombé que partiellement alors
aujourd'hui les pays occidentaux disent
que la porte est ouverte certains pays
comme la France et les États-Unis
forment des pilotes Ukrainiens la
Belgique a rejoint la coalition
internationale qui vise à fournir à
l'Ukraine la capacité aérienne de combat
la Pologne et la Slovaquie ont déjà
fourni des avions de type soviétique mig
et quant aux Ukrainiens ils font leur
compte comme ils avaient pu compter en
fait sur un club des chars léopards 14
pays en Europe sont équipés de ce type
de genre allemand il mis sur un club des
F16 il y en a 9 pays en Europe pour
enfin développer la livraison de cet
appareil qui est à la fois polyvalent et
bon marché mais il faudra encore
convaincre le pays
principal les États-Unis de réexporter
ses F-16 et donc de renoncer à une ligne
rouge
là-bas est dans le camp de Washington
mais les hésitations ont plutôt les
terres diversations sont à peu près dans
tous les pays européens alors il est
possible même probable que dans les
semaines qui viennent tous ces obstacles
soient levés mais pour certains pays
c'est pas inévitable se fait à reculons
d'où l'impression de CO de confusion
alors pourquoi qu'est-ce qu'on redoute
nous les occidentaux avec cette
livraison des avions sont les mêmes que
pour les chars lourds les Européens et
les Américains redoutent une nouvelle
escalade de la part de Vladimir Poutine
pourtant cette escalade n'a pas du tout
eu lieu avec les chats russes et on
s'aperçoit que depuis de le début de la
guerre la Russie a laissé filer toutes
les supposés lignes rouges qu'elle avait
instauré vis-à-vis de l'aide
occidentale les Américains et les
Européens reprochent eux enfin ont aussi
peur que les Ukrainiens en profitent
pour frapper des des villes russes avec
ses avions de chasse là aussi ça ne
s'est jamais produit quand les
Ukrainiens ont frappé des objectifs
Russes et des objectifs militaires et
ils ont fait bien attention de ne pas le
faire avec du matériel qui leur avait
été livré par les Occidentaux donc on
perd du temps à tergiverser si je
comprends perd du temps c'est ce qu'on
pense en Ukraine et en Europe orientale
parce que finalement la meilleure façon
de terminer vite la guerre pense-t-il
c'est de livrer le plus vite possible
aux Ukrainiens tous les matériels qui
leur permettraient de se débarrasser de
fin de chasser les forces russes et pour
leur territoire et l'Ukraine aujourd'hui
a besoin d'avions de chasse à la fois
pour frapper en profondeur les troupes
russes pour contrôler le ciel pour
pouvoir détruire les stocks d'artillerie
qui sont très nombreux en Crimée et
pouvoir pouvoir aussi protéger ses
forces terrestres pendant la
contre-offensive mais aussi après la
contre-offensive alors finalement c'est
l'histoire du verre à moitié plein ou à
moitié vide côté à moitié vide on
s'aperçoit que l'Europe est lente que
les démocraties occidentales sont lentes
et côté à moitié plein on a encore une
fois la preuve que l'Europe progresse et
se transforme dans les grilles dans le
vide que et on ne peut pas la guerre en
Ukraine est un caractère vertueux sur
l'Europe en plus contre toute attente
elle est restée unie et d'ailleurs la
coalition internationale est à la fois
une preuve et un garant de cette unité
un mode réaction oui en fait je vois
énormément de parallèle entre ce que
vous dites sur la perception de la
menace russe et en fait
la perception de la menace djihadiste
c'est-à-dire qu'il a fallu attendre
malheureusement que les temps crus
s'enfoncent la frontière acrylienne pour
réaliser ce dont on
aveuglement sur Poutine et comparable
parfois l'aveuglement qu'on a sur le
jihad merci beaucoup la colère et
l'oubli c'est-à-dire chez Gallimard les
démocratie face au djihadisme européen
merci les affranchis à très vite alors
CV c'est un petit pause c'est le weekend
de l'Ascension on va se retrouver la
semaine prochaine très belle soirée sur
LCP bien sûr
[Musique]